one of the most fascinating things about
creativity is that the most recent
studies are showing that it's not just
one side of the brain or the other side
of the brain that everybody will tell
you it really is the most creative
people are using both sides of the brain
together so this is important concept
that the brain is subdivided into two
major hemispheres we have two of each
structure almost all the structures of
our brain are paired so the idea is well
one side of the brain is important for
certain things and the other side of the
brain is important for other things and
the one thing we can say for sure is yes
language is on the left side of the
brain but for creativity it actually
makes more sense to me that with a
function so broad as that you would
benefit from having the most crosstalk
possible between all parts of your brain
in fact that's exactly what the
neuroscience is showing so then once we
start to understand we're starting to
understand a little bit about about the
brain circuits involved in creativity it
involves a lot the prefrontal cortex as
you might as you might expect then the
question is well how do I up my
creativity that's what everybody is
interested in well there is exciting new
evidence that one of the functions of
the hippocampus a area that we know is
important for long-term memory is that
it's not only important for long-term
memory but it's critical for the
function of imagination so people have
been testing people with other people or
patients with damage to their hippocampi
for long periods of time no surprise
they had memory impairments they were M
music but one day an experimenter back
in 2007 tested a music patients on tasks
of imagination and she asked them can
you imagine a situation that you've
never experienced before in this case it
was imagine a tropical beach and she
compared their responses to people age
match and education match people without
hippocampal damage what she found was
these hippocampal patients these M music
patients who had normal language
abilities were unable to imagine a
future scenario they could say things
like well there's blue ocean there might
be sand
but they couldn't elaborate at all
where's control patients consult control
subjects we're able to talk all about
you know what the beach look like the
buildings on the beach the boats going
past them and this led other researchers
to image the brains of subjects normal
subjects as they were remembering things
and when they remember things the
hippocampus lit out but then they asked
well imagine something new and in that
situation the hippocampus lit up again
so there's multiple modes of evidence
suggesting the hippocampus it's not only
involved in memory but it's also
important for imagination a key
component of creativity we know that
exercise stimulates what we call
neurogenesis or the birth of brand-new
brain cells in the hippocampus but
because of those brand new brain cells
in my hippocampus I'm also enhancing my
imagination abilities so hypothesis that
I'm working on in my lab is can exercise
actually enhance creativity
[Music]